In her two years in Baghdad, Hannah Allam lost over 10 close friends. She was dragged from her hotel in the middle of the night by Iraqi police. She was caught in an attack on a shrine. And things got so bad and lasted so long that she called her mom on her cell phone, thinking she might not make it out of there.
在巴格达的两年里，汉娜·阿拉姆失去了超过10位挚友。她曾在半夜被伊拉克警察从酒店带走。她曾身陷一场针对圣地的袭击。情况变得如此糟糕，且持续了太久，以至于她曾用手机给母亲打电话，以为自己可能无法活着离开那里。
Then a few weeks ago she took a break from her job as Baghdad bureau chief for the Knight-Ridder Newspapers and game home to the Midwest.
几周前，她结束了作为奈特里德报业集团（Knight-Ridder Newspapers）巴格达分社社长的工作，回到了中西部家中。
What struck me most coming back this time, this is the longest I've spent in the states in two years, and it does not seem to me like this country is at war. I was just in the airport here in Oklahoma-- Will Rogers International Airport-- and I was waiting on a flight, and a female soldier in full camouflage got off a plane and it was clear she had just come from Iraq, and was kind of looking around and people were looking at her as if she had come from Mars. And it struck me that what was going through people's heads was, oh, yeah, there's a war going on. I mean, just that was the looks on their faces.
这次回来，最让我感触的是——这是我两年来在美国待的时间最长的一次——这个国家看起来一点也不像是在打仗。我当时就在俄克拉荷马州的威尔·罗杰斯国际机场等着航班，一位全副武装的女兵下了飞机，很明显她刚从伊拉克回来。她有些茫然地四处张望，而周围的人看着她，就好像她来自火星一样。我突然意识到，人们脑子里想的可能是：哦，对啊，还在打仗呢。我是说，这就是他们脸上的表情。
You know, I live in Oklahoma, I go to Walmart, I'm an Okie. I mean, generally, the conversation goes, oh, can I have your zip code. Oh, I live overseas. Where? Baghdad. Oh, Baghdad. Wow. Well, you must be happy it's going so much better there now. And me, stunned silence. And me, mumbling, yeah, yeah, OK. Where do I sign, and getting out of the shop.
要知道，我就住在俄克拉荷马州，我去沃尔玛，我就是个土生土长的俄克拉荷马人。通常对话会是这样：“能告诉我您的邮编吗？”“哦，我住在国外。”“在哪？”“巴格达。”“哦，巴格达。哇。那你一定很高兴那里现在好多了吧。”而我，只能惊愕地沉默，嘟囔着“是啊，是啊，好的”，签好字，赶紧离开店里。
Right. This is you actually just giving your visa card to somebody and you're like yeah, yeah.
没错，这就是你正把信用卡递给某人，然后随口应付着“是啊，是啊”。
I get that comment a lot. And people want so much for it to be going well. Sometimes I just can't bear to tell them that it's horrible, or that I lost so many friends, or whatever. I don't. I don't say it.
我经常收到这样的评论。人们太渴望事情正在好转了。有时候我实在不忍心告诉他们情况有多糟糕，或者我失去了多少朋友等等。我不会，我不会说出来。
It's hard though, soldiers are risking their lives, contractors are risking their lives, she and her staff of reporters are risking their lives, and it's not even for something people are paying attention to? Captain Chuck Ziegenfuss has seen some of the same things now that he's back in the states. Here's the commander of Charlie Company 234 armor in Iraq. He was blown off the road by an IED in June 2005. Shrapnel in his legs, arms, and face. He woke up two weeks later at a hospital in the states. He says that Fort Riley in Kansas where he lives, so many people have been sent overseas. It's a military community, there's no escaping the reality of the war.
但这很难，士兵们在拿生命冒险，承包商在拿生命冒险，她和她的记者团队也在拿生命冒险，可这些事情甚至都没能引起人们的关注？查克·齐根福斯上尉现在回到了美国，他也看到了同样的事情。他是伊拉克第234装甲营C连的连长。2005年6月，他的车被简易爆炸装置（IED）炸翻，双腿、双臂和面部都被弹片击中。两周后，他在美国的一家医院醒来。他说，在他居住的堪萨斯州赖利堡，太多人被派往海外。这是一个军事社区，战争的现实是无法逃避的。
But when I watch the news and even the local news coming out of Topeka, they cover Iraq in the world minute. It's like an aside to what's going on with the wheat report. And I think a lot of people are just kind of getting on with their lives and although they realize there's a war going on, unless it personally affects them, they don't see it as a war like we saw the second world war or even Korea. They see it as more of an over there, but it doesn't apply to them.
但当我观看新闻，甚至是托皮卡当地的新闻时，他们只用一分钟播报伊拉克的情况。就好像那只是小麦产量报告之外的一个附带内容。我认为很多人只是在继续他们的生活，尽管他们知道正在打仗，但除非战争亲身影响到他们，否则他们不会像看待第二次世界大战甚至朝鲜战争那样看待这场战争。他们觉得那更像是在“那边”发生的事，与他们无关。
It doesn't anger me that people don't realize there's a war going on, it disappoints me. So it's hard to explain, but I don't want to get into the crowd that says, you weren't there, you don't understand. It's something that can be explained, just in a lot more detail than you would see in a 60-minute TV show or even an excerpt on the radio.
人们没有意识到战争正在发生，这并不会让我愤怒，只会让我感到失望。这很难解释，但我不想加入那种说“你没去过那里，你不懂”的群体。这其实是可以解释的，只是需要比60分钟的电视节目或电台节目的片段更详细的内容。
Take the body count. It's been in the news all this week because the number of American soldiers dead in Iraq passed 2,000.
以死亡人数为例。这整个星期都在新闻里，因为在伊拉克阵亡的美国士兵人数超过了2000人。
The body count, to me is probably the most offensive thing as it scrolls past on headline news or things like that because it's not about what we've lost, it's about what we've done and what those 2,000 people were doing when they were killed. Like myself, what was I doing when I was wounded? I was trying to keep a road open and safe for not just my soldiers, but for the people that travel on it every day. Now that I'm included in the X number of people that have been wounded in Iraq, I'm more than a statistic, and what I did over in Iraq is more than statistics.
对我来说，死亡人数可能是最令人反感的东西，因为它在头条新闻上滚动播报，但这关乎的不是我们失去了什么，而是我们做了什么，以及那2000人在被杀害时正在做什么。就像我自己，我受伤时在做什么？我当时正试图为我的士兵，也为每天在路上行驶的平民保持道路畅通和安全。现在我被列入在伊拉克受伤的人数统计中，但我不仅仅是一个数字，我在伊拉克所做的一切也不仅仅是统计数据。
It seems like every day we hear these numbers and facts come and go, car bombings, more deaths. All really fast, without a lot of explanation. And today on our radio program, we just try to slow down, and understand better one particular number from Iraq, and what it means, really. From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass.
似乎每天我们都在听到这些数字和事实，汽车炸弹，更多的死亡。一切都非常快，没有太多的解释。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们只是尝试放慢脚步，更好地理解来自伊拉克的某一个特定数字，以及它到底意味着什么。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，节目是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
In act one of our show we're going to talk about a number and a quick news story that nobody really seemed to take very seriously at the time that it happened and what was really behind it. In act two, the Air Force drops a bombs on the wrong target in Sunni Iraq and accidentally kills 12 people, including children. An army captain has to go apologize and try to make things right. A journalist was with them and recorded this very difficult moment. Act three, what do we do with these numbers anyway? Stay with us.
在节目的第一幕，我们将讨论一个数字，以及一个当时似乎没人当回事的快讯，揭示其背后的真相。在第二幕，美国空军在伊拉克逊尼派地区轰炸了错误目标，意外造成12人死亡，其中包括儿童。一位陆军上尉不得不去道歉，并试图弥补。一位记者与他们同行，记录下了这个非常困难的时刻。第三幕，我们到底该如何看待这些数字？请留下来。
Act one, Truths, Damn Truths, and Statistics. The number we're going to talk about right now is not how many Americans have died in the Iraq war, but how many Iraqis have. The fact is we have no idea how many civilians have died as a result of the war. Nobody counts. Not the military, not the State Department. The Iraqi Ministry of Health for a good while early on in the war, was compiling morgue figures from across the country, and making them public every week. But that practice was stopped. These days, the place that most people go when they need a figure is a privately run, nonprofit website called Iraqbodycount.net. It gets its figures by going through newspaper articles and other press accounts and simply counting the number of people reported dead in those articles.
第一幕：真相、该死的真相和统计数据。我们现在要谈论的数字不是在伊拉克战争中死去的美国士兵人数，而是死去的伊拉克平民人数。事实是我们根本不知道有多少平民因战争而死亡。没人统计。军方不统计，国务院也不统计。战争初期，伊拉克卫生部曾有一段时间汇总了全国各地的停尸房数据，并每周公开。但这种做法后来停止了。如今，大多数人在需要数字时会去一个私人运营的非营利网站，叫Iraqbodycount.net。它通过查阅报纸文章和其他新闻报道，简单地计算那些报道中记录的死亡人数来得出数据。
Even the people who started the site and who run it today freely admit that this method gives you a huge undercount. At best it's a minimum. The true number could be much, much higher. One of the producers of our radio show, Alex Blumberg, started looking into all of this. And he found something surprising and disturbing about the death figures, and what we know about them. Here he is.
即便是创办该网站并运营至今的人也坦率地承认，这种方法得出的数字存在巨大的遗漏。充其量它只是一个最低限度。真实数字可能会高得多得多。我们广播节目的制片人之一亚历克斯·布伦伯格开始研究这一切。他发现了一些关于死亡数字以及我们所知信息的令人惊讶且不安的情况。请听他的报道。
Eveyone will tell you, counting civilian casualties in wartime is hard. First of all, you need to do something called a large-scale mortality study. And second of all, you need to do it in the middle of a war zone. To date in Iraq, there's only been one attempt. It was a Johns Hopkins University Study published in The Lancet, a British medical journal, in late October 2004, a couple of days before the US presidential election.
每个人都会告诉你，在战时统计平民伤亡是很困难的。首先，你需要进行所谓的“大规模死亡率研究”。其次，你需要在战区中心地带进行这项研究。迄今为止，在伊拉克只有一次这样的尝试。那就是2004年10月下旬，即美国总统大选前几天，英国医学杂志《柳叶刀》发表的一项约翰霍普金斯大学的研究。
It concluded that probably 100,000 Iraqis had died as a result of the war. This figure was astonishingly high. 10 times higher than any casualty estimates at the time. Even today, a year later, with all the extra deaths that have happened in that year, no other estimate comes close. Just this week, the New York Times ran a story based on the Iraq body count website that's estimating civilian casualties at a fraction of that number, just 30,000.
该研究结论认为，可能有10万伊拉克人因战争而死亡。这个数字高得惊人。是当时任何伤亡估计的10倍。即使在今天，一年过去了，又发生了这么多额外的死亡，也没有其他估计能接近这个数字。就在本周，《纽约时报》发表了一篇基于Iraqbodycount网站的文章，估计的平民伤亡人数只有这个数字的一小部分，仅为3万。
Since The Lancet study's figures were so high and the study itself got almost no traction in the press, I remember thinking at the time it came out, that it's probably bogus and slanted. I'm guessing a lot of people, if they even heard about the study, felt the same way. But recently, in trying to figure out how many civilians have died in the war, I've learned more about The Lancet study. And the more I learned about it and the remarkable story of how it was done, the more likely it seems that the 100,000 is actually the best estimate. And if anything, low.
由于《柳叶刀》研究的数字如此之高，且该研究在媒体上几乎没有引起什么反响，我记得当时它出来时，我心里想这很可能是虚假的、有偏见的。我猜很多即便听说过这项研究的人也有同感。但最近，在试图弄清楚到底有多少平民在战争中丧生时，我进一步了解了《柳叶刀》的研究。了解得越多，以及得知它是如何完成的非凡故事，我就越觉得10万这个数字实际上是最好的估计。如果说有什么问题的话，那就是估计偏低了。
Before the Iraq study the main thing I was known for and that I had testified in front of Congress for was documenting how many people had died in the war in the Congo.
在伊拉克研究之前，我主要以记录刚果战争中死亡人数而闻名，我甚至为此在国会作证过。
This is Les Roberts, the lead author on The Lancet study and one of a handful of scientists in the world who could be called, an expert in counting war dead. In the Congo study, he found that 1.7 million civilians had died from the war, a figure cited by Colin Powell when he was secretary of state, and Tony Blair on the floor of the British parliament. Les has also done studies in Burundi, Rwanda, and Sierra Leon.
这就是莱斯·罗伯茨，《柳叶刀》研究的主要作者，也是世界上少数几个可以被称为“战时死亡统计专家”的人之一。在刚果的研究中，他发现有170万平民因战争而死亡，这个数字曾被时任国务卿科林·鲍威尔和托尼·布莱尔在英国议会引用。莱斯还在布隆迪、卢旺达和塞拉利昂做过研究。
To a guy in Les Robert's line of work, the war in Iraq had a number of unique and interesting things that deserved study. The main thing that distinguished this work was that the military took unprecedented care to avoid civilian casualties. Almost 2/3 of the bombs dropped were precision guided, as compared to just 8% in the first Gulf War, and 0% in World War II. They limited daytime strikes and avoided civilian infrastructure, like power and sewer plants. Compare that to World War II where American forces fire-bombed entire cities as part of the military strategy, killing up to 100,000 people in Tokyo alone, and upwards of half a million civilians in Europe, and you can see why George Bush called the Iraq War one of the most quote, "humane military campaigns in history."
对于莱斯·罗伯茨这一行的人来说，伊拉克战争中有很多独特且有趣的地方值得研究。这项工作的最大特点是军方采取了史无前例的谨慎态度来避免平民伤亡。近2/3的炸弹是精确制导的，而在第一次海湾战争中这一比例仅为8%，在第二次世界大战中则为0%。他们限制了白天的空袭，并避免针对平民基础设施，如电力和污水处理厂。将其与第二次世界大战进行比较，当时美军作为军事战略的一部分火攻了整个城市，仅在东京就造成多达10万人死亡，在欧洲造成超过50万平民死亡，你就能明白为什么乔治·布什称伊拉克战争是历史上“最人道的军事行动之一”。
But Les knew that often it's not bombs and bullets that kill people in war, it's the other things that happen when society falls apart. Clean water and medical supplies get scarce. In a lot of the studies he did in Africa, diarrhea killed more people than weapons did. Women can't get to the hospital to deliver their babies, so infant mortality rates go up as well.
但莱斯知道，在战争中夺去人们生命的往往不是炸弹和子弹，而是社会崩溃后发生的其他事情。清洁饮用水和医疗物资变得匮乏。在他于非洲所做的大量研究中，腹泻造成的死亡人数比武器造成的还要多。妇女无法去医院分娩，因此婴儿死亡率也随之上升。
It took Les a long time to get to Iraq and see if the same things were happening there. First, an Iraqi doctor who he'd plan to work with died in an auto accident, another social ill, by the way, that tends to increase during wartime. And then insurgent violence spiked. It wasn't until August of 2004, five months after he'd originally planned to go, that he finally landed in Amman, Jordan. He had $24,000 in foundation money in his pocket, his passport, and a letter of invitation from the Iraqi Ministry of Education. He found a driver, a retired Iraqi army officer named Wahid, who agreed to take him to Baghdad.
莱斯花了很长时间才到达伊拉克，看看那里是否也在发生同样的事情。首先，他计划合作的一位伊拉克医生在一场车祸中丧生——顺便说一下，这也是战时倾向于增加的一种社会疾病。接着，叛乱暴力激增。直到2004年8月，也就是他原计划出发5个月后，他才终于降落在约旦安曼。他口袋里揣着2.4万美元的基金资助、护照，以及一封来自伊拉克教育部的邀请函。他找了一位名叫瓦希德的退休伊拉克军官做司机，对方同意带他去巴格达。
Problems started at the very first checkpoint, on the border between Jordan and Iraq.
问题在第一个检查站，也就是约旦和伊拉克的边境就开始了。
Wahid takes my passport, he takes my letter of invitation, and he goes. And he comes out just a few minutes later and he is just terrified. Turns out he bumped into a former friend of his from his military days. And he had pulled out my passport in front of him and his friend just, like, blanched and pushed the passport back into his pocket and said, you have an American here, are you crazy? Don't let anyone see that. Just get the hell out of here and don't let me see you again. You idiot!
瓦希德拿了我的护照，拿着邀请函，走了过去。几分钟后他出来时，整个人都被吓坏了。原来他碰到了他军队时期的一位老朋友。他在对方面前拿出了我的护照，结果他朋友脸色惨白，把护照塞回他口袋里说：“你竟然带了个美国人，你疯了吗？别让任何人看见。赶紧滚，别再让我看到你。你这白痴！”
Fortunately for Les, Wahid was something of a Han Solo figure, an unenthusiastic, but talented smuggler who didn't look for trouble, but didn't run away from it once it found him. He talked his way through that first checkpoint.
幸运的是，对于莱斯来说，瓦希德是个有点像韩·索罗式的人物，一个不情愿但有本事的走私者，他不找麻烦，但麻烦找上门来时也不会逃避。他靠嘴皮子闯过了第一个检查站。
And we drive up a couple of miles and he pulls off the road behind this abandoned old gas station. And in the upholstery of his car he's got hidden another pair of license plates with a different color. And he's got another registration form to go with those license plates. So quickly, he gets out and he changes his license plates. And he says, look, you must lie down. You must stay hidden. And so I spent the next, whatever, eight hours lying on the floor. And we actually had to go through two extra points where they stopped and looked around in the car and he chatted with folks. And here I am, I'm lying down behind the back seat on the floor.
我们开车走了几英里，他把车开离公路，停在了一个废弃的老加油站后面。他在汽车的内饰里还藏着另一副不同颜色的车牌，还有一套与那些车牌配套的注册表格。他迅速下车换了车牌。他说：“听着，你必须躺下。你必须保持隐藏。”所以接下来的八个小时左右，我就一直躺在地板上。我们实际上还经过了两个额外的检查点，他们停下来搜查车子，而他在和人们闲聊。我就躺在后座后面的地板上。
So when they stopped and looked around, you were actually hiding from them?
所以当他们停下来搜查时，你实际上是在躲着他们？
That's right.
没错。
And were you scared?
你害怕吗？
That's a funny thing. I had consciously made the decision that it was worth trading my life for a chance at getting a realistic estimate of how many Iraqi civilians have died and how they've died, so I was quite at peace with the notion of dying when I went.
这很有意思。我当时已经清醒地决定，为了获得关于有多少伊拉克平民死亡以及他们是如何死亡的现实估计，冒生命危险是值得的，所以当我出发时，我已经坦然接受了死亡的念头。
Les finally made it to Baghdad, where he met for the first time in person, his Iraqi co-researcher, the man with whom he'd be working for the next month. His name was Riyadh Lafta and he was a doctor of community medicine at Al-Mustansiriya University in Baghdad. Riyadh had hired a team of researchers, mostly doctors from his university. All of them native Iraqis, but fluent in English.
莱斯终于到达了巴格达，并在那里第一次亲自见到了他的伊拉克联合研究员，也就是他接下来一个月将要共事的人。他的名字叫利雅德·拉夫塔，是巴格达穆斯坦西里亚大学的社区医学博士。利雅德聘请了一个研究小组，大部分是来自他大学的医生。他们都是伊拉克本地人，但英语流利。
Let's pause here a moment to talk about their methodology. Because when their study came out later, a lot of people wanted to believe that it was flawed or biased. In fact, the survey team used a standard methodology for measuring health and mortality over a geographic area. It's called a cluster sample survey and it works like this.
我们在这里暂停一下，谈谈他们的方法论。因为当他们的研究后来发布时，很多人都想相信它是存在缺陷或偏见的。事实上，调查小组使用的是一种测量特定地理区域内健康和死亡率的标准方法。它被称为“整群抽样调查”，运作方式如下：
Using the most recent census figures available in Iraq, the team made what was essentially, a map of the population. They then used a random number generator to pick 33 points on that map. Baghdad was the biggest population center, so it got several points by itself. But the other points were spread all over the country, from the Kurdish north to the Shiite south, from small towns to big cities.
利用伊拉克现有最新的普查数字，研究小组绘制了一张本质上的“人口地图”。然后，他们使用随机数生成器在地图上选择了33个点。巴格达是最大的人口中心，所以它本身就占了几个点。但其他点分散在全国各地，从库尔德人的北部到什叶派的南部，从城镇到大城市。
Once they'd picked a town though, the team still had to figure out who to interview there. Here again, they worked hard to leave everything to chance. Using GPS units, they would drive around the outskirts of the town and store the coordinates, creating a rough outline of the town border. They would then generate a random point within that border, drive to it, and interview the 30 nearest households. It was such a commitment to random sampling that the first few times the team did it, even the researchers Les and Riyadh were working with, found it obsessive.
不过，一旦选定了一个城镇，团队仍然必须弄清楚要在那里采访谁。在这里，他们同样努力把一切交给偶然。他们使用GPS设备在城镇郊区开车，记录坐标，勾勒出城镇边界的大致轮廓。然后，他们在边界内生成一个随机点，驱车前往，并采访附近的30户人家。他们对随机抽样的执着程度，以至于最初几次，就连莱斯和利雅德共事的研究员都觉得这很偏执。
It was very annoying to them because here they are in the car. They're out, they're feeling like they're at risk. And they'd be driving around for a long time to get to the extremes of a city and draw their map before they interviewed the first house. They're like driving around and not getting any work done they felt.
他们对此感到非常恼火，因为他们坐在车里，身处险境，却得开很长时间的车去城市的边缘画图，然后再去采访第一户人家。他们觉得一直在开车，却没干成什么正事。
And this is all just to make it as scientifically valid as possible, right?
而这一切只是为了让结果尽可能具有科学依据，对吧？
This is a way of picking houses without any sort of preference for safe neighborhoods, dangerous neighborhoods, near the highway, far from the highway. It was a way of sort of transcending human laziness so that, in essence, every household in Iraq had an equal chance we would visit them. And that is, in essence, the definition of random.
这是一种选择住户的方法，不带任何对安全社区、危险社区、靠近高速公路或远离高速公路的偏好。这是一种超越人类懒惰的方法，从本质上讲，伊拉克的每一户人家都有平等的几率被我们访问。这本质上就是“随机”的定义。
The survey went smoothly, at least for the first couple of days. People, it turned out, were much more willing to answer questions. Even to provide death certificates as verification, than the researchers had initially thought they'd be. In fact, the trouble, when it came, came from Les himself.
调查进行得很顺利，至少在最初几天是这样。事实证明，人们回答问题的意愿比研究人员最初预想的要高得多，甚至愿意提供死亡证明作为验证。事实上，麻烦出现时，是因为莱斯本人。
Must be about the fifth day I was out with them, the eighth cluster I attended. I, and two of the interviewers were up in a town to the north called Balad. And there was a huge picture of the cleric Sadr as you rolled into Balad. So clearly, it was an anti-coalition city in a big way.
那一定是我和他们外出的第五天，我参与的第八个集群。我和两名采访员在北部一个叫巴拉德的城镇。当你进入巴拉德时，那儿有一张巨大的萨德尔神职人员的照片。显然，那是一个反联军色彩浓厚的城市。
Sadr of Sadr militia?
萨德尔民兵的萨德尔？
Of the Sadr militia, that's right. And as fate would have it, the first or the second door they knocked on was the governor's house. And so somebody calls the police.
是的，萨德尔民兵的。命运弄人，他们敲开的第一或第二扇门竟然是总督的家。于是有人报了警。
Les watched from the car as the police took the two researchers-- both doctors, one a dignified man in his 50s and the other a single mother-- and drove them away. He was terrified that somehow the police would find out that they were working with him, an American. But he could do nothing but sit in the parked car and hope no one discovered him.
莱斯在车里看着警察把两名研究人员——都是医生，一位是50多岁庄重的人，另一位是单身母亲——带走了。他非常恐惧，担心警察会发现他们正在和一个美国人一起工作。但他除了坐在停放的车里，祈祷没人发现他，什么也做不了。
I had done everything I could to be invisible. I wore boring Iraqi clothing. I had dyed my hair black. I had grown a beard, so I would look right. But it still didn't look right. They had made up a fake business card that said, Dr. Abdul Salaam. That I was from Bosnia because that would explain me being blue-eyed, non-Arabic speaking. But I could still be a Muslim and that would make me OK. I was just so worried that us sitting there for an exorbitant length of time would draw attention that I put the back of the passenger seat down and I sort of laid on my side to pretend I was asleep, so I wouldn't have to speak to anyone if anyone came to the window of the car.
我尽了一切努力让自己变得隐形。我穿着不起眼的伊拉克衣服，把头发染成了黑色，留了胡子，好让自己看起来像当地人。但看起来还是不像。他们伪造了一张名片，上面写着“阿卜杜勒·萨拉姆医生”，说我来自波斯尼亚，因为那样可以解释为什么我蓝眼睛、不说阿拉伯语，但我依然可以是穆斯林，那样也就没事了。我太担心我们长时间停在那里会引起注意，所以我就把副驾驶座靠背放平，侧身躺着假装睡觉，这样如果有人来到车窗前，我就不必开口说话。
And I had probably been lying on my side for about 20, 30 minutes and these two little kids, they might have been 10, they came up to the window beside where I was, they stuck their head in the car, they looked around, and I'm pretending to be asleep. And they said to me, in English, hello mister. And you know, even with my eyes closed pretending to be asleep, there's just no way I could pretend I was an Iraqi. And there was no way around it, so that was a pretty just horrifying experience all around. And I'm wondering have I gotten these two lovely interviewers arrested or killed? And after an hour or a little more, a car brought back the two interviewers and they went right back to work. They didn't come to the car. They didn't look at us. They didn't acknowledge us. They just went right back to work and finished out the 30 houses randomly picked in that neighborhood and off we went.
我可能已经侧身躺了大约20到30分钟，两个小孩子，可能才10岁吧，走到我旁边的车窗旁，把头探进车里看了看。我假装在睡觉，他们用英语对我说了声：“你好，先生。”你知道，即使我闭着眼睛假装睡觉，也不可能假装自己是伊拉克人。这是没办法的事，所以那是一次非常恐怖的经历。我心想，我害这两位可爱的采访员被捕或被杀了吗？一个多小时后，一辆车把那两位采访员送了回来，他们立刻回到了工作状态。他们没有来车边，没有看我们，没有理会我们。他们只是直接回去完成了那个社区随机选出的30户人家的采访，然后我们就离开了。
But after that day, no interviewer ever spoke to me again. Not in person.
但从那天起，再也没有采访员跟我说过话。不是面对面的那种。
Riyadh and Les decided that for everyone's safety, he should lay as low as possible. So for the next 16 days straight he didn't leave his hotel. To pass the time he crunched the numbers that the survey teams were calling into him every night.
利雅德和莱斯决定，为了每个人的安全，他应该尽量隐蔽。于是接下来的16天里，他没有离开过酒店。为了打发时间，他整理着调查小组每晚打来的数据。
The surveyors were getting basically two pieces of information from each household. How many people in that household had died in the 14 months before the invasion, and of what, and when? And how many had died in the 17 months after the invasion, and of what, and when?
调查人员基本上从每户人家获得了两条信息：在入侵前的14个月里，这户人家有多少人死亡，死于什么原因，什么时候死的？以及入侵后的17个月里，有多少人死亡，死于什么原因，什么时候死的？
By the time the teams had completed their 32nd out of 33 clusters, over 900 households, and over 7,000 people, the results were pretty shocking. The death rate itself had gone up about 60%. Large increase, but one that Les had expected from his other surveys. The shocker was how people were dying. For the first time in any of his surveys, the leading cause of death wasn't disease, it was bombs and bullets. In the 32 of the 33 clusters sampled, 21 people died of violence, as compared to just 1 violent death in the period before the war.
当团队完成了33个集群中的第32个，调查了超过900户人家、7000多人时，结果令人震惊。死亡率本身上升了约60%。这是一个巨大的增长，但莱斯从他的其他调查中也预料到了这一点。令人震惊的是人们死亡的方式。在他所有的调查中，死因第一位首次不是疾病，而是炸弹和子弹。在抽样的33个集群中的32个里，有21人死于暴力，而在战前同期仅有1例暴力死亡。
There was a second shocker. Of those 21, 2 people died in firefights where it was unclear where the bullet came from. 3 were killed by insurgents or Saddam loyalists. 7 died from criminal violence, carjackings, revenge killings, that sort of thing. And the biggest number, 9, were killed by the American-led coalition.
第二个震惊之处在于，这21人中，2人死于原因不明的交火；3人被叛乱分子或萨达姆忠诚分子杀害；7人死于犯罪暴力、劫车或复仇杀戮；人数最多的是9人，死于以美国为首的联军之手。
I just didn't expect violence from the coalition to have dominated the causes of death in Iraq. In no way reading the New York Times and listening to National Public Radio would I have believed that the coalition killed far, far, far more people than did the insurgents setting off car bombs.
我根本没想到联军造成的暴力会成为伊拉克死亡原因的主导。仅仅通过阅读《纽约时报》和收听国家公共广播电台，我绝不会相信联军杀害的人数远比引爆炸弹的叛乱分子要多得多。
I should mention that only three of them involved guys with guns. All the rest were helicopter gunships and bombs from planes, so it's not about individual soldiers doing bad things. In fact, two of those three cases when soldiers shot civilians with their guns, they actually went to the houses of the decedents and apologized to the families. There's no evidence here of soldiers running amok. There's evidence here of a style of engagement that probably has relied very heavily on air power that has resulted in a lot of civilian deaths.
我应该提到，其中只有三人涉及持枪人员。其余全是武装直升机和从飞机上投下的炸弹，所以这不是士兵个人做了坏事的问题。事实上，在士兵用枪射杀平民的三起案例中，他们中有两次实际上去了死者家中向家属道歉。这里没有证据表明士兵在胡作非为，证据表明的是一种可能非常依赖空中力量的交战风格，导致了大量平民死亡。
I was at a presentation last November and a Pentagon spokesperson said that they've dropped about 50,000 bombs in Iraq. 50,000 bombs. Very, very small fraction of them would need to miss their target or be based on bad information to explain 100,000 civilian deaths.
去年11月我在一个演讲会上，五角大楼发言人说他们在伊拉克投下了约5万枚炸弹。5万枚炸弹。其中只要极小极小一部分错失目标或基于错误情报，就足以解释10万平民死亡的原因。
At the end of three weeks, there was only one more cluster to survey. The team had saved it for the end because it was the most dangerous one: Fallujah.
三周结束时，只剩下一个集群需要调查。团队把它留到了最后，因为这是最危险的一个：费卢杰。
Remember, this is September 2004, insurgents control the city and it's basically under siege from the coalition. They're shelling it regularly.
记住，这是2004年9月，叛乱分子控制了这座城市，它基本上正处于联军的围困之下，并定期遭到炮击。
It just seems crazy to go there. And I said to Riyadh, Riyadh, we have been to 32 of our 33 picked neighborhoods. We actually only thought in the end we would get to 30. We had aimed for 30 and picked 33 with the thought that 10% of places would be too unstable for us to get to. So we've done better than we expected. We have a terrible story to tell, the mortality is way up. Whatever you find in Fallujah is not going to change the story. Think of what we're going to gain. We're going to gain nothing. And he said, God picked those random locations. God wants me to do this work. I must do this. And we went back and forth and back and forth and back and forth and-- I was brought up Catholic, and I had never really thought about it or understood it until that moment in time.
去那里似乎太疯狂了。我对利雅德说：“利雅德，我们已经去了33个目标社区中的32个。其实我们最终只打算去30个。我们原本瞄准30个，选了33个，想着有10%的地方可能太不稳定去不了。所以我们做得比预期还好。我们有一个可怕的故事要讲，死亡率大幅上升。无论你在费卢杰发现什么，都不会改变这个故事。想想我们要得到什么？我们什么也得不到。”他说：“上帝选了这些随机位置。上帝要我做这项工作。我必须这样做。”我们反复争论，争论不休……我是天主教徒，在那一刻之前，我从未真正思考或理解过这一点。
But in my head, I actually sort of build up a weight. What's the likelihood of something bad going to happen to these guys, and how bad is that? What's the likelihood of something good coming from what they do? And how good is that? And I sort of put a weight on each of them and as I spoke with Riyadh, he actually did not have the capacity to do that. Because for him, doing God's will and this work were inseparable. He couldn't separate out risk because that was separating out sort of faith. The more we spoke, the more I understood that on some very, very fundamental level that we couldn't communicate with each other about our motives here. And in the end, he went.
但在我的脑海里，我实际上建立了一个权衡。这些人发生不幸的可能性有多大，情况会多糟糕？他们所做的事情带来好结果的可能性有多大？会有多好？我对每一个都加上了权重。当我和利雅德交谈时，他实际上没有那种能力。因为对他来说，做上帝的旨意和这项工作是密不可分的。他无法剥离出风险，因为那意味着剥离出某种信仰。我们谈得越多，就越明白在某个非常非常根本的层面上，我们无法就我们的动机进行交流。最终，他去了。
Only one other interviewer agreed to go to Fallujah with Riyadh, a doctor who had relatives there he wanted to check up on. Their car was stopped three times on the way into the city. Heading to their random spot, they saw devastation everywhere. Houses were bombed, rubble lay in the streets. The block they stopped on was no different. They had to visit 52 households to get the requisite number of interviews. 23 homes were either temporarily or permanently abandoned. Neighbors said that in the abandoned houses, most people had died. But this data couldn't be substantiated, so it wasn't even included in the survey results.
只有另一名采访员同意和利雅德去费卢杰，那位医生有亲戚在那里，他想去看看。他们进入城市的途中车被拦下了三次。前往随机抽样点时，他们随处可见破坏。房屋被炸毁，瓦砾堆满街道。他们停下的街区也没什么不同。他们不得不走访了52户人家才获得所需的采访数量。23所房屋要么暂时，要么永久废弃。邻居们说，在废弃的房屋里，大多数人都死了。但这些数据无法核实，所以甚至没被计入调查结果中。
In the 30 households they did survey, there were 53 deaths. 52 of these were violent deaths, all but one caused by coalition weapons. 24 of the people killed by coalition bombs and bullets were children under 12 years old. And with that, the survey was over.
在他们调查的30户人家中，发生了53起死亡。其中52起是暴力死亡，除一起外，其余均由联军武器造成。死于联军炸弹和子弹的24人是12岁以下的儿童。至此，调查结束。
Five days and counting, tonight the newest polls, the latest trends, and breaking developments from the campaign trail on America's News Live.
距离大选还有五天，今晚是《美国新闻直播》关于竞选活动的最新的民调、最新趋势和突发动态。
This is Fox Evening News October 28, 2004, on the day the results of Les' survey that just shy of 100,000 Iraqis had died as a result of the war were released. Les had not even considered the Fallujah data in coming up with this number. Fallujah had so many deaths, it was too much of a statistical outlier to even include.
这是2004年10月28日的《福克斯晚间新闻》，即莱斯关于伊拉克战争导致近10万人死亡的调查结果公布的那天。莱斯在得出这个数字时甚至没有考虑费卢杰的数据。费卢杰的死亡人数太多了，是一个统计学上的极端离群值，甚至无法包含在内。
Fox never mentioned the study, neither did ABC or CBS. The only national network that carried the story was NBC for 21 seconds.
福克斯从未提及这项研究，ABC或CBS也没有。唯一报道这一新闻的全国性电视网是NBC，时长21秒。
Tom, thanks, and we begin here with Iraq Watch tonight and one measure of the high cost of war. A new study from Johns Hopkins University estimates that 100,000 Iraqi civilians have died since the start of the war. The majority as a result of US air strikes. This is a much larger figure than some previous estimates. The Pentagon had no comment on the number, but said it had taken great care to prevent civilian deaths. And there is word--
“汤姆，谢谢。我们从今晚的伊拉克观察开始，这是战争高昂代价的一个衡量指标。约翰霍普金斯大学的一项新研究估计，自战争开始以来，已有10万伊拉克平民死亡。其中大多数是美国空袭造成的。这个数字远高于此前的一些估计。五角大楼未对这个数字发表评论，但表示已采取巨大努力来防止平民死亡。另外有消息称——”
Morning Edition and All things Considered on NPR, devoted 45 seconds to the story. And it didn't make the front page of the New York Times , the Washington Post , or any national newspaper. The Iraq study had provided information about the war that up until that point, no one had been able to provide. The number it gave was much higher than anyone would have expected. It was just as accurate as Les' previous studies in Africa that he'd done using the exact same methods and which were widely reported in the press and quoted by lawmakers. His Congo study was page one in the New York Times .
NPR的《早间版》和《一切考虑在内》节目仅用了45秒报道这则新闻。它也没有登上《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》或任何全国性报纸的头版。这项伊拉克研究提供了直到那时还没人能够提供的关于战争的信息。它给出的数字远高于任何人的预期。它与莱斯之前在非洲利用完全相同的方法所做并在媒体上广泛报道、被议员引用的研究一样准确。他的刚果研究曾是《纽约时报》的头版新闻。
The only differences with the study were that he'd risked his life to do it and it was about Iraq. Which, if anything, should have made it more interesting to the media. So why didn't it get any press?
这项研究唯一的不同之处在于，他冒着生命危险去做，而且是关于伊拉克的。这本应让它对媒体更有吸引力才对。那么为什么它没有得到任何媒体报道呢？
Partly, it was the timing. The study came out five days before the US election, and so the media was pretty preoccupied. Plus, there was a suspicion that the team had timed the release of the survey specifically to influence the election, a suspicion that Les didn't really help dispel. He said to an AP reporter about the study quote, "I emailed it on September 30 under the condition that it come out before the election. My motive in doing that was not to skew the election. My motive was, that if this came out during the campaign, both candidates would be forced to pledge to protect civilian lives in Iraq. I was opposed to the war and I still think the war was a bad idea, but I think that our science has transcended our perspectives. As an American, I'm really, really sorry to be reporting this."
部分原因是时机。研究在大选前五天公布，所以媒体非常忙碌。此外，有人怀疑研究小组专门选择这个时机公布调查结果是为了影响选举，莱斯并没有很好地消除这种怀疑。他曾对美联社记者谈到该研究时说：“我在9月30日通过电子邮件发送了它，条件是它必须在大选前公布。我这样做的动机不是为了干扰大选。我的动机是，如果这在竞选期间公布，两位候选人都将被迫承诺保护伊拉克平民的生命。我反对战争，直到现在我也认为发动战争是个坏主意，但我认为我们的科学已经超越了我们的观点。作为一个美国人，我真的、真的很遗憾要报告这一点。”
One desk editor at a national news organization told me that when the study came out he sent an email to one of his colleagues saying, "The Lancet had in the past, published some studies with a political slant, but that this study seemed sound and maybe they should report on it." Then he saw Les' comments and he didn't follow up. This is exactly the type of story that those who believe the media has a liberal bias love to pounce on. And so, in essence, if the research turns out to be flawed, this desk editor's organization gets the heat for it. He had a very small window of time during a very busy news cycle to decide whether the study was legit or just an angry and easily debunked researcher pushing an agenda. And Les' comments seemed to be all the evidence he needed.
一家全国性新闻机构的编辑告诉我，当研究出来时，他给同事发了一封邮件说：“《柳叶刀》过去曾发表过一些带有政治倾向的研究，但这项研究看起来是扎实的，也许我们应该报道一下。”然后他看到了莱斯的评论，就没有再跟进。这正是那些认为媒体存在自由派偏见的人喜欢抓住的那种故事。所以本质上，如果研究结果被证明有缺陷，这位编辑所在的机构就会受到攻击。他在非常繁忙的新闻周期中，只有很短的时间来决定这项研究是合法的，还是一个愤怒且容易被揭穿的研究人员在推动某种议程。而莱斯的评论似乎是他所需要的全部证据。
And there was one other thing that made it easy for the media to dismiss the report. A researcher at Human Rights Watch, who himself had done studies of civilian casualties during wartime said he didn't believe the study. The researcher's name was Marc Garlasco, and he told a reporter for the Washington Post quote, "The number seems high to me." And quote, "It seems like a stretch."
还有一件事让媒体很容易驳回该报告。人权观察组织的一名研究员，他本人曾在战时做过平民伤亡研究，说他不相信这项研究。这名研究员名叫马克·加拉斯科，他告诉《华盛顿邮报》的一名记者：“这个数字对我来说太高了。”并且说：“这看起来有点牵强。”
I was actually on the Long Island Railroad when he called me. It was sometime in the evening and I had yet to read Les' report.
他给我打电话时，我实际上正在长岛铁路的火车上。那是晚上的某个时候，我还没读过莱斯的报告。
This is Marc Garlasco. He said he told the reporter from the Post that he hadn't read the study, but the reporter said he really needed a quote and could he just respond to the number. Garlasco's quote was cited elsewhere and he appeared on CNN, although none of the study's authors were interviewed on CNN, or any of the major networks. Here's what Marc Garlasco says now.
这就是马克·加拉斯科。他说他告诉《华盛顿邮报》的记者他还没读过这项研究，但记者说他真的很需要引用，能不能只对这个数字做出回应。加拉斯科的引言在其他地方被引用了，他还在CNN上露了面，尽管研究的作者中没有一人在CNN或任何大型电视网接受过采访。这是马克·加拉斯科现在所说的。
First of all, I'm not a statistician. I know absolutely nothing about it. And when I then went and spoke to statisticians they said, well, the method that he's using is a really accurate one. This is something that we use in studies all throughout the world and it's a generally accepted model. That kind of made me think about it. Think about my prejudices going into reading his report because I had been on the ground in Iraq immediately after the war. But I also had taken part in the targeting for the war.
“首先，我不是统计学家。我对此一窍不通。当我后来去和统计学家交谈时，他们说，他使用的方法确实非常准确。这是我们在全世界的研究中都会使用的方法，是一个普遍接受的模型。这让我开始思考。思考我在阅读他的报告之前所带有的偏见，因为我在战后立刻就在伊拉克实地待过。但我也参与过战争的瞄准工作。”
OK, let's just stop here for one minute. You heard what he said. He'd taken part in the targeting for the war. Get ready, because this story's about to take a turn. Marc Garlasco isn't your typical human rights advocate.
好的，我们在这里停一分钟。你们听到了他说的。他参与过战争的瞄准工作。做好准备，因为这个故事要发生转变了。马克·加拉斯科不是你典型的人权倡导者。
Well, I worked in the Pentagon almost seven years, and my last job there was chief of high-value targeting on the joint staff. And basically, that means that I was one of many people that was involved in the tracking and attempted killing of Saddam Hussein and all those people in the deck of cards. And I would sit there with my compatriots and we would put X's on buildings one day, and the next day those buildings are gone.
“我在五角大楼工作了近七年，最后一份工作是联合参谋部的高价值瞄准负责人。基本意思就是，我是参与追踪和试图杀害萨达姆·侯赛因以及那些扑克牌上所有人物的众多人员之一。我会和我的同僚坐在那里，有一天我们在建筑上打上X，第二天那些建筑就不见了。”
So you were literally in this invasion?
所以你实际上参与了这次入侵？
Absolutely, I was involved in the war planning. In January of '03 I was involved in the final targeting of Iraq, when we put the final target lists together. And of course, those got brushed up as we got closer to the war. During the war I was working 18 hours a day, at least, in the Pentagon. You know, putting in hours trying to get and kill Saddam Hussein and others. And after Baghdad fell, then on April the 11 I walked out of the Pentagon and it was a Friday. And then on Monday morning I walked into Human Rights Watch and suddenly I'm now a human rights advocate. And got on a plane and flew to Iraq to see my handiwork.
“当然，我参与了战争策划。在03年1月，我参与了对伊拉克的最终瞄准工作，当时我们制定了最终目标清单。当然，随着我们接近战争，这些清单又进行了润色。战争期间，我在五角大楼每天至少工作18个小时。你知道，投入数小时试图定位并消灭萨达姆和其他人。巴格达陷落后，4月11日，那是星期五，我走出了五角大楼。然后星期一早上，我走进了人权观察组织，突然之间，我现在成了人权倡导者。我登上一架飞机飞往伊拉克，去看看我的手艺。”
Literally, like how soon after?
字面意思上，到底是在那之后多久？
Literally, it was just the next week. Got onto a plane and went to Iraq. And I was standing there in craters that I had helped cause.
“真的是就在下周。坐上飞机去了伊拉克。我就站在那些我曾经协助造成的弹坑里。”
Marc doesn't see moving from the Pentagon to a human rights nonprofit as the 180 degree flip most people might. He says all he's ever wanted to do was fight bad guys, and both organizations do that, just in different ways. He'd been thinking about leaving the military before the war began and he hadn't supported the war himself. But he stayed through the fall of Baghdad because he knew the targets better than anyone else. And he figured if there was going to be a war anyway, might as well be him targeting the bombs rather than someone else who might not know or care as much as he did.
马克并不认为从五角大楼转到人权非营利组织是大多数人可能认为的180度大转变。他说他一直想做的就是打击坏人，这两个组织都做到了，只是方式不同。他在战争开始前就考虑离开军方，他本人并不支持战争。但他一直待到巴格达陷落，因为他比任何人都更了解目标。他想如果无论如何都要打仗，那么由他来瞄准炸弹，总好过由其他人来，因为他们可能不像他那样了解或关心。
The thing that finally prompted him to leave, he says, didn't have anything to do with the war. His wife got a great job offer at the Bronx Zoo and they'd always wanted to move back to New York. When Marc went with Human Rights Watch to Iraq, it wasn't to get a comprehensive count of civilian casualties. His mission was to look at specific attacks and see which kinds of attacks caused high civilian death tolls. Because Marc had planned many of the strikes he was now going to investigate, it was a little complicated.
他说，最终促使他离开的事情与战争无关。他的妻子在布朗克斯动物园得到了一份很好的工作机会，他们一直想搬回纽约。当马克随人权观察组织去伊拉克时，并不是为了获得平民伤亡的全面统计。他的任务是观察特定袭击，看看哪些袭击造成了高平民死亡人数。因为马克策划了许多他现在要去调查的空袭，情况有点复杂。
There was the attack on Chemical Ali in Basra and I'll never forget sitting in this tiny cubicle in the bowels of the Pentagon watching it on the television as we had the predator overhead. And you're watching this black and white screen because it's a night shot and anything that's white is hot and black is cold. And we were watching people walking in front of it and all of a sudden this building just erupts and was gone. And we watched as bodies flew out of it. And you could see the legs kicking in the air like rag dolls. And we just erupted in cheers and we were ecstatic. You know, here we are, we killed Chemical Ali. This is great.
“当时对巴士拉的‘化学阿里’进行了袭击，我永远不会忘记坐在五角大楼深处那小隔间里，在电视上看它，因为当时有无人机在上空。你看着那个黑白屏幕，因为是夜间拍摄，任何白色的东西都是热的，黑色的东西是冷的。我们看着人们在它前面走，突然那座建筑爆发了，消失了。我们看着尸体从中飞出。你可以看到腿像布娃娃一样在空中踢动。我们爆发出一阵欢呼，当时简直欣喜若狂。你知道，我们在那里杀死了‘化学阿里’。太棒了。”
And, what is it, three weeks later? I'm standing in the crater with this 70-year-old man who's got tears in his eyes and he's telling me how 17 members of his family, including his grandchildren, were killed. And I still feel very-- I have very mixed emotions about the whole situation, the whole experience.
“然后，过了多久，三个星期吧？我站在那个弹坑里，和一个眼里含着泪水的70岁老人在一起，他告诉我他的17名家人，包括他的孙辈，是如何被杀害的。我对整个局势、整个经历，仍然有着非常复杂的感情。”
What are those mixed emotions, like on the one side and on the other?
那些复杂的感情是什么样的，比如一方面和另一方面？
Well, on the one side, I feel like I took part in this wholesale slaughter of this guy's family, which is very difficult to swallow. But on the other side I know that we truly, truly did what we could. We were going after some very bad people. You know, war criminals. Chemical Ali had gassed the Kurds. He was singularly responsible for thousands of deaths. And so he was certainly a legitimate military target. But I think this just goes to show how difficult the job really is. You know, this is one of those strikes where we did everything right, where we thought we had the bad guy, where it was weaponeered correctly, and yet, it just was the wrong place to hit at that time and people died for it.
“嗯，一方面，我觉得我参与了这家人被集体屠杀的过程，这非常难以接受。但另一方面，我知道我们确实尽了我们所能。我们针对的是一些非常坏的人。你知道，战犯。‘化学阿里’曾经用毒气攻击过库尔德人。他单凭一人就应对成千上万人的死亡负责。因此他当然是一个合法的军事目标。但我认为这恰恰证明了这份工作到底有多困难。你知道，这是一次打击，我们做了所有正确的事情，我们认为我们抓住了坏人，我们的武器装备也做得正确，然而，那在当时是一个错误的攻击地点，人们因此付出了生命。”
The attack had hit the intended buildings, but it also destroyed the two neighboring buildings. That's where the man's family had died. Also, Chemical Ali hadn't been in the targeted building anyway. It's unclear who died there.
袭击击中了预定目标建筑，但它也摧毁了两个邻近建筑。那是那家人的家人死亡的地方。另外，当时“化学阿里”根本不在那个目标建筑里。不清楚到底是谁死在那里。
Marc went to lots of places in Iraq he'd studied on maps and aerial photographs and heard about from defectors. And there's no way around this, after all those years of imagining these places, what they must be like, it was exciting to actually be there.
马克去了伊拉克许多他曾在地图和航空照片上研究过、并从叛逃者那里听说过的地方。没办法，在想象了这些地方这么多年、想过它们一定是什么样之后，真正亲临那里确实令人兴奋。
I was walking through bunkers that I knew about. I went to Saddam Hussein's bunker. I went to his family's bunkers. One of my favorite moments was when I actually met one of the bunker builders and hired him as a translator. And he took us into Sajida's palace and Sajida was Saddam's wife. And we knew that there was a bunker under the building and we had targeted it and dropped a weapon into it. And he took me in and we go into the building and I'm seeing the inside for the first time, which had before only been described to me by defectors. And here it is and this picture that had been painted in my mind. And we get there and the guy says, now I will walk you down to the bunker. And we walked down to it and we get to the bunker. And when we look down on it from the top, there's a hole-- as the Penetrator went in-- through the four floors straight down into the bunker. And he looks at me and he says, whoever did this was a very smart man. And I lost it. I just completely lost it.
“我在我了解的掩体里走着。我去了萨达姆·侯赛因的掩体。我去了他家人的掩体。我最喜欢的时刻之一是我真的遇见了一位掩体建筑师，并雇他做了翻译。他带我们进了萨吉达的宫殿，萨吉达是萨达姆的妻子。我们知道大楼下面有一个掩体，我们瞄准了它，并投下了一枚武器进去。他带我进去，我们进入大楼，我第一次亲眼看到了内部，这以前只有叛逃者向我描述过。就在这儿，那幅在我脑海中描绘的画面。我们到了那儿，那个人说，‘现在我带你下到掩体里。’我们走下去，到了掩体。当我们从上方往下看时，有一个洞——那是穿甲弹打进去的——穿过四层楼直接打进了掩体。他看着我，说：‘不管是谁做的，都是个非常聪明的人。’我崩溃了。我彻底崩溃了。”
Because you're like, I did that.
因为你心里想：我做的。
I was like, hey, thanks. I appreciate it.
“我当时是说：嘿，谢谢。我欣赏这一点。”
The military denied my request to talk on the record about civilian casualties. But Marc Garlasco says that civilian casualties are one of the primary factors he and his colleagues considered when planning the war. Say he had a target he wanted to take out. The headquarters of the Iraqi Secret Service maybe, or one of Saddam's palaces. He'd work with the weaponeering guys to figure out how many and which bombs to use. And then--
军方拒绝了我关于平民伤亡进行记录在案的谈话请求。但马克·加拉斯科说，平民伤亡是他和同事在策划战争时考虑的首要因素之一。假设他有一个想要清除的目标。可能是伊拉克特务机关的总部，或者是萨达姆的宫殿之一。他会和负责武器配备的人一起计算要使用多少枚炸弹以及使用哪种。然后——
Once that's established, they'll work up these collateral damage estimates. And tell you, OK, in this strike 10 people are anticipated to be killed-- civilians. Or 20 civilians, or whatever. And in this war in Iraq, there was a magic number, and the magic number was 30. And for any target where it was anticipated that 30 civilians or more would be killed, it required the signature of either the President or the Secretary of Defense for that strike to actually occur.
“一旦确定下来，他们就会制定这些附带损害评估。告诉你，好的，在这次打击中，预计会有10人死亡——平民。或者是20名平民，以此类推。在伊拉克的这场战争中，有一个魔术数字，那个数字是30。对于任何预计会有30名或以上平民死亡的目标，必须有总统或国防部长的亲笔签名，该打击才能真正实施。”
How was that magic number arrived at, do you know?
这个魔术数字是怎么得来的，你知道吗？
I have absolutely no idea how the magic number came to be 30.
我完全不知道这个30的魔术数字是怎么来的。
A lot of times when the collateral damage assessment came back too high, they would try to get it lowered. For example, a strike Marc planned early on in the invasion. An Iraqi division was holed up in a big, multi-building convention center in Baghdad. Which unfortunately, was right across the street from a hospital.
很多时候，当附带损害评估结果过高时，他们会试图降低它。例如，马克在入侵初期策划的一次打击。一个伊拉克师盘踞在巴格达一个大型多建筑会议中心内。不幸的是，它就在一家医院街对面。
Now because of the amount of guys there and the construction of the buildings, we knew that they needed to use 2,000 pound bombs. The problem with this is a 2,000 pound bomb has a very large, destructive radius. And it certainly would have enveloped the hospital. But there are things that you can do, even when you're dropping large munitions, to reduce civilian casualties. One of those is to change the angle of attack.
“由于那里的士兵人数和建筑结构，我们知道他们需要使用2000磅重的炸弹。问题在于，2000磅炸弹有很大的破坏半径。它肯定会覆盖医院。但即使你投掷大型弹药，也有一些事情可以做来减少平民伤亡。其中之一就是改变攻击角度。”
And so imagine if you will, a plane is coming in and drops bombs at such an angle that they actually push the debris away from the direction of the hospital. Additionally, you put a time delayed fuse on it. And in this case, I think it was maybe five nano seconds, which is an incredibly short period of time, but it's enough that allows the bomb to bury itself in the ground. And what this does is, it basically lets the building implode. And it falls in upon itself and contains a lot of that blast and fragmentation damage that would come out and injure civilians, or destroy some of the hospital. And then additionally, you're using a penetrating warhead, so it's burying into the ground. So you're not just willy-nilly dropping bombs like in the second world war.
“想象一下，飞机进来投下炸弹的角度使它们实际上将碎片从医院的方向推开。此外，你在上面加装一个延时引信。在这种情况下，我想可能是5纳秒左右，这是极短的时间，但足以让炸弹埋入地下。这样做的结果是，它基本上会让大楼向内坍塌。它自身塌陷，包含了很多本来会射出并伤害平民或摧毁医院部分设施的爆炸和碎片损害。另外，你使用的是穿甲弹头，所以它会埋入地下。所以你不是像二战那样漫无目的地乱扔炸弹。”
And when I got there I went into the hospital and spoke to the director and all the people in there. And you know, nothing worse than a few broken windows. And I was like, wow, this is great. We did a really good job on this one.
“当我到达那里时，我进了医院，和院长以及那里所有的人交谈。你知道，最坏的情况也只是几扇窗户被打破。我当时想：哇，这太棒了。我们在这次任务上做得非常出色。”
What got Marc thinking about civilian casualties in the first place was a battle damage assessment he did after the war in Kosovo. He targeted the bombs for that war and then afterwards the military sent him over to see how well he'd done. He measured how often the bombs hit their targets, whether they'd destroyed what they were supposed to destroy. Pretty much the only thing he didn't check the accuracy of were the collateral damage assessments.
让马克开始思考平民伤亡的，是他在科索沃战争后做的战后评估。他为那场战争瞄准了炸弹，随后军方派他去看看他做得怎么样。他测量了炸弹命中目标的频率，是否摧毁了它们应该摧毁的东西。他几乎唯一没有检查准确性的就是附带损害评估。
That's what got me. That's what really surprised me. At no point in time did we ever have to report back on civilian casualties. And so my question has always been, if you're looking if the weapons worked correctly, if the targets were correct, shouldn't you also be asking, were your civilian casualty estimates correct? I mean, shouldn't that be factored into it to make sure that your models are accurate? Because if your models are not accurate, what are they worth? You know, why do you even bother doing it? Because it's just throwing darts at a board at that point.
“那就是抓住我的地方。那才是真正让我感到惊讶的地方。我们从未有任何时候需要报告平民伤亡。所以我的问题一直都是，如果你在看武器是否运作正确，目标是否正确，你不应该同时也问问，你的平民伤亡估计准确吗？我是说，这不应该被纳入考虑以确保你的模型是准确的吗？因为如果你的模型不准确，它们还有什么价值？你知道，你为什么要费心做这件事？因为在那一点上，这就像是在飞镖板上乱投飞镖。”
Wow, did you ever find out an answer to that question?
哇，你有没有找到这个问题的答案？
No, but it's something that I keep asking the military now that I'm in Human Rights Watch. You know, when I was there I was wondering, why isn't it done. And now I ask them why isn't it done and why don't you do it? And you know, I guess the answer that I get back just hasn't satisfied me.
“没有，但现在我在人权观察组织工作，我一直在问军方这个问题。你知道，我那时在想，为什么不这么做。现在我问他们为什么不这么做，为什么你们不这么做？你知道，我想我得到的回答并没有让我满意。”
It's we're still fighting a war in Iraq, it's really hard to do. Or it's very difficult to account for civilian casualties for a variety of reasons. And you get kind of the bureaucratic double talk. And it's just not good enough because I've been there and I know that people care and want to do the very best they can. And they don't want to kill civilians. And here's an opportunity to really make a difference and to show that you're doing your utmost best to make sure that you're upholding the Geneva Convention and not killing people unnecessarily.
“‘我们还在伊拉克打仗，这真的很难做。’或者‘由于各种原因，很难统计平民伤亡。’你会得到那种官僚式的打官腔。这还不够好，因为我去过那里，我知道人们很关心，想要尽他们最大的努力。他们不想杀害平民。这里有一个机会真正发挥作用，表明你在竭尽全力确保你遵守《日内瓦公约》，而不是不必要地杀害人们。”
In talking to people in the military off the record, I heard a couple of arguments against counting civilian deaths. First they say, it's not the military's job. If what you're trying to do is win a battle, it could be a dangerous, and in the long run, counterproductive distraction to worry about counting all the civilians you accidentally kill along the way. Second, and perhaps more persuasively, they say no one would believe them anyway. Just ask Les Roberts.
在非正式采访军方人员时，我听到了几个反对统计平民死亡的理由。首先他们说，这不是军方的工作。如果你试图赢得一场战斗，担心统计你沿途意外杀害的所有平民可能会是一个危险的、从长远来看适得其反的干扰。其次，也许更有说服力的是，他们说反正也没人会相信他们。问问莱斯·罗伯茨就知道了。
Even though Les' study didn't get much mainstream attention, it did provoke, like so many things these days, a bitter debate on the internet. The attacks came mainly, though not exclusively, from right wing blogs. Several charges leveled that the study were simply untrue and seemed designed to willfully muddy the waters.
尽管莱斯的研究没有得到太多主流媒体的关注，但正如当今许多事情一样，它确实在互联网上引发了一场激烈的辩论。攻击主要来自右翼博客，虽不完全限于此。几项针对研究的指控简直是虚假的，似乎旨在蓄意搅浑水。
For example, there was a claim repeatedly made, both in the press and online, that the data weren't random because the researchers had been blocked from going certain places, or had decided against certain places because it was too dangerous. This is simply false.
例如，媒体和网络上一再声称数据不随机，因为研究人员被禁止前往某些地方，或者因为太危险而决定不去某些地方。这简直是胡说八道。
A couple people suggested that the researchers had gone to Fallujah on purpose to boost their numbers, even though exactly the opposite was true. Les had wanted to skip Fallujah altogether and they hadn't even included the data in their final casualty estimate.
一些人建议研究人员故意去费卢杰是为了提高数字，尽管事实恰恰相反。莱斯本来想完全跳过费卢杰，他们甚至没把那些数据计入最终的伤亡估计中。
Several objections had merit, though. First of all, the study makes no distinction between combatants and civilians. Les actually acknowledged this in the study itself and went to great lengths not to claim, as others did on his behalf, that the study was a measure of civilian mortality. Certainly, some of the people the coalition killed they intended to kill. But half of all the casualties were women and children, so even in the unlikely event that 50% of the men who died were actually fighting us, it's still a large number of innocents.
不过，几项反对意见确实有道理。首先，该研究没有区分战斗人员和平民。莱斯在研究本身中实际上承认了这一点，并尽了很大努力不去声称——正如其他人代表他所做的那样——该研究是平民死亡率的衡量指标。当然，联军杀害的人中确实有一些是他们意图杀害的。但所有伤亡中有一半是妇女和儿童，所以即使假设死亡的男人中有50%的人实际上在与我们战斗（这种可能性很小），那仍然有大量的无辜者。
The critique that got most traction on the internet though, has to do with something called the confidence interval. Let's take an election poll as an example.
然而，在互联网上获得最多反响的批评与所谓的“置信区间”有关。让我们以竞选民调为例。
If candidate X is projected to receive 55% of the vote, what that really means is that he's projected to receive some percentage within two numbers. Let's say 52% and 58%. That range is called the confidence interval. The confidence interval in Les' survey was very wide, between 8,000 and 194,000. It was this wide for a lot of reasons, but mainly because the sample is relatively small relative to the population, and because violent death, unlike death due to malaria or diarrhea, isn't very uniformly distributed. So you have Kurdish areas where mortality actually went down during the war versus Fallujah, which averaged almost two violent deaths per household. Such a wide confidence interval means that statistically speaking, Les' estimate of 100,000 dead isn't very precise. The number could be thousands or tens of thousand smaller. Or equally likely, bigger.
如果候选人X预计获得55%的选票，那真正意味着他预计会在两个数字之间获得某个百分比。假设是52%和58%。那个范围被称为置信区间。莱斯调查中的置信区间非常宽，在8000到194000之间。这个区间如此宽有许多原因，但主要是因为样本量相对于人口较小，而且因为暴力死亡不同于疟疾或腹泻导致的死亡，分布并不非常均匀。所以你会有库尔德地区，战争期间死亡率实际上有所下降，而费卢杰则平均每户人家几乎有两起暴力死亡。如此宽的置信区间意味着，从统计学上讲，莱斯对10万死亡人数的估计并不非常精确。这个数字可能会少几千或几万，或者同样可能，更多。
But a lot of people made wrong conclusions from the wide confidence interval. They interpreted it to mean it was just as likely that 8,000 people had died as it was that 100,000 had. The online magazine, Slate , wrote "This isn't an estimate, it's a dart board." In fact, the likelihood follows a bell curve, with 98,000 being at the top of the bell, the most likely number. So actually, there's only a 2.5% chance that the number is 8,000 or below, but a 90% chance that it's 44,000 or above. Here's Les.
但很多人从宽阔的置信区间得出了错误的结论。他们将其解释为：死亡8000人和死亡10万人是同样可能的。在线杂志《Slate》写道：“这不是一个估计，这是一个飞镖盘。”事实上，概率遵循钟形曲线，98000位于钟形顶端，是最可能的数字。所以实际上，数字在8000或以下的几率只有2.5%，而数字在44000或以上的几率则有90%。这是莱斯说的。
A couple of people told me that Sunday before the election, their minister from the pulpit had said this study in The Lancet was flawed and wrong. And my next door neighbor, who was listening to talk radio, spoke to me the day of the election and she said, well I just heard on talk radio today that The Lancet study finding 8,000 Iraqi deaths was flawed and wrong. And so it was discussed, but I don't think it was discussed in a very sort of scientifically rigorous process.
“选举前那个星期天，有几个人告诉我，他们的牧师在讲坛上说《柳叶刀》的这项研究是错误的。我的邻居在听谈话广播，大选当天跟我说，‘我今天在谈话广播里刚听到说《柳叶刀》研究发现伊拉克死亡8000人是错误的。’所以它被讨论了，但我认为并没有通过一种非常科学严谨的过程进行讨论。”
Clearly, the people on talk radio weren't attacking the study out of a commitment to experimental rigor. They were attacking it for the same reason that the news media was hesitant to report it. Because the very act of counting civilian casualties is political. The moral logic of war is this. We're willing to undergo X number of costs in lives, money, resources, to accomplish some goal. The goal we hope will be worth it in the end. So assuming the goal in Iraq is good, is it wrong to kill 100,000 civilians?
显然，谈话广播节目中的人攻击该研究并不是出于对实验严谨性的追求。他们攻击它是为了与新闻媒体犹豫是否报道它相同的原因。因为统计平民伤亡的行为本身就是政治性的。战争的道德逻辑是这样的：我们愿意付出X数量的生命、金钱、资源成本来达成某种目标。我们希望这个目标最终是值得的。那么假设伊拉克的目标是好的，杀害10万平民是错误的吗？
Saddam, himself, probably killed 230,000 of his own people. A number, by the way, no one seems to go out of their way to dispute. If you add the million or so lives he lost in the futile war he launched against Iran, 100,000 seems like a bargain in comparison. Maybe he would have gone another killing spree and this 100,000 is insurance against the later, far worse death toll. Or Maybe 100,000 lives is worth it if in the end, democracy does blossom through the Middle East. After all, we killed far more Japanese with just two atomic bombs than, according to Les, we did in a year and a half in Iraq.
萨达姆本人可能杀害了他自己的人民中的23万。顺便说一下，没人似乎特意去质疑这个数字。如果你加上他在对伊朗发动的徒劳战争中损失的约一百万生命，10万相比之下似乎很划算。也许他会继续另一场杀戮狂潮，而这10万是防止后来更糟糕死亡人数的保险。或者也许，如果我们最终在整个中东看到了民主的开花结果，10万生命就是值得的。毕竟，正如莱斯所言，我们仅仅用两颗原子弹杀死的日本人就比我们在伊拉克一年半杀死的还要多。
If we don't count civilian casualties, we don't have to get into this kind of horrible math. And most of us don't want to. So instead, we leave it to the professionals. The military are the only ones who even try to come up with a formula, the collateral damage assessment. 30 dead civilians for 1 bad guy.
如果我们不统计平民伤亡，我们就不用陷入这种可怕的数学中。而我们大多数人也不想。所以相反，我们把这项工作留给专业人员。军方是唯一尝试提出公式的人，即附带损害评估：每死一个坏人，30名平民死亡。
For Les, he doesn't really care who counts, just so long as someone does.
对于莱斯来说，他并不真正在乎是谁在统计，只要有人做就行。
Under the Geneva Conventions, an occupying army's relationship to the occupied is roughly the same as a police department's relationship to its population. And in my hometown if a policeman pulls out his gun and shoots six shots at someone, another policeman will come and try to find where each of those six bullets landed and decide, was this excessive use of force? Well, how can we say that we are really looking after the well being of the Iraqi people, if we don't sort of go through some sort of minimal effort to decide, what are we doing to them and what can we do to limit the adverse consequences?
“根据《日内瓦公约》，占领军与被占领者的关系大约相当于警察部门与其人口的关系。在我家乡，如果一名警察掏出枪向某人开了六枪，另一名警察会过来试图寻找那六颗子弹每一颗落在了哪里，并决定：这是过度使用武力吗？那么，如果我们不采取最低限度的努力来决定我们对他们做了什么，以及我们能做什么来限制负面后果，我们怎么能说我们真的在照顾伊拉克人民的福祉呢？”
One of the most surprising things Les discovered in Iraq is that despite what everyone says about the difficulty of counting civilian casualties during wartime, it's actually not that hard. The survey teams got participation rates that most American pollsters would kill for. Only 5 of the 988 households the team surveyed refused to answer the questions. And people were able to provide death certificates over 80% of the time. That confidence interval? Les is sure that based on the results of the first survey and with a little more money-- remember, this whole thing cost only $40,000-- he could design a follow-up survey that would narrow that interval way down.
莱斯在伊拉克发现的最令人惊讶的事情之一是，尽管每个人都谈论战时统计平民伤亡的困难，但实际上并没有那么难。调查小组获得的参与率是大多数美国民调机构求之不得的。在团队调查的988户人家中，只有5户拒绝回答问题。而且人们在80%以上的情况下能够提供死亡证明。那个置信区间？莱斯确信，基于第一次调查的结果，再加上一点钱——记住，整个项目只花了4万美元——他可以设计一个后续调查，将那个区间缩小很多。
We can count civilian casualties in wartime, we just have to want to.
我们可以在战时统计平民伤亡，我们只需要想要去做。
Alex Blumberg. Coming up, so a military that's trying as hard as it can not to kill civilians makes a mistake. What do they do then? Well, we have a recording to play for you of what they do then. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
亚历克斯·布伦伯格。接下来，一个正在尽最大努力不杀害平民的军队犯了一个错误。他们会怎么做？嗯，我们有一段录音放给你们听，听听他们之后是怎么做的。片刻之后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, What's in a Number? In act one of our program we heard about the number of Iraqi deaths that occurred in the first year and a half of the war there. And how the majority of those deaths, according to this Johns Hopkins study, were caused by US led forces. Now we're going to move to act two, where we hear US forces trying to cope in the aftermath of some of those deaths. This is act two, Not just a Number.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择某个主题，为您带来各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《数字代表什么？》。在节目的第一幕，我们听说了伊拉克战争前一年半发生的死亡人数。以及根据这项约翰霍普金斯大学的研究，这些死亡中大多数是由以美国为首的部队造成的。现在我们进入第二幕，我们听到美军试图在那些死亡之后进行应对。这是第二幕，不仅仅是一个数字。
The civilian deaths in this particular story came at a unusually bad time for captain Ryan Gist. He was the American officer in charge of the US army presence in a section of the Nineveh and Salahuddin Provinces in Iraq, a Sunni area. And this meant that he dealt with everything from seeing that the region had water and fuel, to dislodging insurgents and winning over the local population. He faced all sorts of problems.
这个故事中的平民死亡事件对瑞安·吉斯特上尉来说发生在一个极其糟糕的时刻。他是负责伊拉克尼尼微省和萨拉赫丁省部分地区（一个逊尼派地区）美军驻扎的美国指挥官。这意味着他要处理从确保该地区有水和燃料，到清除叛乱分子以及争取当地民众的所有事务。他面临着各种各样的问题。
On November 10, 2004, for example, insurgents blew up most of the police stations in his area. And the next day, Iraqi army and police simply stopped showing up for their jobs. One town called Aitha was especially troublesome. US had not made many allies there.
例如，2004年11月10日，叛乱分子炸毁了他地区内大部分的警察局。第二天，伊拉克军队和警察干脆就不来上班了。一个叫艾塔的小镇尤其麻烦。美国在那里没能争取到多少盟友。
And it was turning into probably the greatest threat to stability in our region. So to begin with, we knew we were going into a very hot spot. We went in and for weeks we'd go in there and we would try and talk to leaders, try and talk to people. And they were scared. The terrorists literally had a grip on everybody. And that is the challenge in Iraq. And what it takes is just feet on the ground every day going to different houses and just talking to people. And finally, we found someone whose family had been killed, every one of them had been killed by the terrorists within the last month, and he wanted revenge. And he wanted to see his town free of this threat.
“它正变成我们地区稳定面临的最大威胁。所以首先，我们知道我们要进入一个非常热门的地区。我们进去了，几个星期以来我们一直进去，试图和领导人谈，和人们谈。他们很害怕。恐怖分子简直控制了每一个人。这就是伊拉克面临的挑战。这需要每天脚踏实地去不同的房子和人们交谈。最终，我们找到了一个人，他的家人全被恐怖分子在过去一个月内杀害了，他想要报复。他想看到他的小镇摆脱这个威胁。”
So the guy gives him names and locations of people that he identifies as insurgents, and the army launches an operation to get those people. And this is where things went wrong. As part of this operation, US forces were supposed to drop a bomb into a nearby field just as a show of force. But instead, the bomb was dropped onto the house that the army was just about to raid, killing 12 people inside, including children. And nearly killing the US troops who were about to go in. That's according to an American photojournalist, Sheryl Mendez, who was there.
于是那个人给了他一些名字和地点，指出谁是叛乱分子，军队发动了一次行动去抓那些人。而事情就在这里出了差错。作为这次行动的一部分，美军本应向附近的田野投下一枚炸弹以展示武力。但相反，炸弹投在了军队正准备突袭的那所房子上，杀死了里面的12人，包括儿童。差点杀死了正准备进去的美军部队。这是根据当时在场的美国摄影记者谢丽尔·门德斯的说法。
In addition to the human tragedy of these deaths, for Captain Gist this could not have been worse.
除了这些死亡的人类悲剧外，对吉斯特上尉来说，情况再糟不过了。
It was the hardest time in my life. And the most difficult part for us was in the weeks afterwards. We had to show that it was an accident and that we are someone who can be trusted and we are here to help them.
“这是我生命中最困难的时刻。对我们来说最困难的部分是在接下来的几个星期。我们必须证明这是一次意外，我们是值得信任的人，我们在这里是为了帮助他们。”
The photographer Sheryl Mendez tape recorded him as he went to the sheiks who were the local leaders and to the police, as he went around trying to make things right. Here's one of those recordings. He's in a police station.
摄影师谢丽尔·门德斯录下了他去找当地领导人（谢赫）和警察，四处奔走试图弥补过错时的录音。这是其中的一段录音。他在一个警察局里。
I'm here for a couple reasons today. The first reason is to express my regrets to you.
“我今天来有两个原因。第一个原因是向你们表达我的遗憾。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（外语交流）
I feel much pain in my heart for what happened.
“我内心对发生的事情感到极大的痛苦。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（外语交流）
We did not intend to hurt any innocent people here.
“我们无意伤害这里的任何无辜平民。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（外语交流）
We did not mean for any women and children to die.
“我们不是故意要让任何妇女和儿童死亡。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（外语交流）
I had men hurt in the explosion as well.
“我的士兵在爆炸中也受了伤。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（外语交流）
You're sitting there in a room with five, six, seven people that are definitely angry at you. They believe you did it intentionally. That hate you for being in the town in the first place.
“你坐在房间里，面对五、六、七个人，他们绝对对你感到愤怒。他们认为你是故意这样做的。他们恨你，因为你出现在那个小镇。”
This is a very sad situation.
“这是一个非常悲伤的局面。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（外语交流）
It's also important that I get all the facts and all the names from you because we will compensate the families of those who were killed and wounded.
“同样重要的是，我从你们那里得到所有事实和所有名字，因为我们将赔偿死伤者的家属。”
And what I just kept repeating and kept saying was, what happened was a horrible mistake. And I want to make amends in whatever way that I can.
“我一直在重复说的话就是，发生的这一切是一个可怕的错误。我想尽我所能进行弥补。”
I know that we cannot bring thdm back, only Allah can do that.
“我知道我们不能让他们复活，只有真主能做到。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（外语交流）
But I hope to be able to help with the healing process.
“但我希望能为治愈过程提供帮助。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（外语交流）
And I'm also here to ensure this does not destroy the relationship we've established with the people of Aitha.
“我在这里也是为了确保这不会破坏我们与艾塔人民建立的关系。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（外语交流）
I know there's a lot to do  to rebuild this relationship and this is my first step. But it's also very important that I get all the facts here. Right now I have 12 names of those who were killed and three that were wounded, so I think I'm missing one here.
“我知道重建这种关系还有很多工作要做，这是我的第一步。但得到所有事实也非常重要。目前我有12个遇难者名单和3个受伤者名单，所以我想我这里漏了一个。”
It seems like such an incredibly awkward thing having to do.
这看起来是一件非常尴尬的事情。
I don't think awkward is at all the word you would use to describe something like this. It was, I mean, possibly the most emotional event of my life, going out and dealing with these people in such incredible grief.
“我不认为尴尬是描述这种事情的合适词汇。那是我一生中最情绪化的事件，面对陷入如此巨大悲痛中的人们。”
Noman Huessein? Afmed Noman?
“努曼·侯赛因？艾哈迈德·努曼？”
No [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
不，（听不清短语）。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
（外语交流）。
Noman.
“努曼。”
努曼。
Akmed.
“艾哈迈德。”
这基本上就是他在这些村庄运作的标准方式。他说，当然，有些村庄和地方领导人同情叛乱分子。但在其他地方，他们是被叛乱分子欺压的。
Addeb.
“阿德布。”
阿德布。
Hasna
“哈斯娜。”
哈斯娜。
Debuyah.
“德布亚。”
德布亚。
Leya.
“莱雅。”
莱雅。
Azizah.
“阿齐扎。”
Aziz.
阿齐兹。
Azizah.
“阿齐扎。”
Azizen.
阿齐赞。
Azizah.
“阿齐扎。”
Azizah. Azizah, that's a woman, you don't know who she is?
阿齐扎。阿齐扎，那是个女人，你不知道她是谁？
What happened after that?
那之后发生了什么？
Well, this took about-- the way it works in the Arabic culture is there's about a 7 to 10 day mourning period, or grieving period after the death. So of course, I wanted to go in there. We're Americans. We want to go in, we want to fix it immediately. I wanted to go in there and make the payments to the families and talk to them and express our regrets. So the hardest thing for me was I couldn't go into the town for seven days. So it was incredibly difficult for me.
“嗯，这花了大约——在阿拉伯文化中，死亡后有7到10天的哀悼期。所以当然，我想进去。我们是美国人。我们想进去，想立刻解决它。我想进去给家属赔偿，跟他们谈谈，表达我们的遗憾。所以对我来说最难的是，我7天内不能进小镇。这让我感到极其困难。”
Because during those 7 to 10 days you're thinking, these people are deciding they hate us and they're spending word about how we killed these people, like it's just the worst thing from a propaganda point of view and winning over people's hearts. That's what your fear is?
因为在那7到10天里你心想，这些人正在决定他们恨我们，他们正在传播关于我们是如何杀死这些人的话，从宣传的角度和争取民心来看这简直是糟糕透了。这是你的恐惧吗？
That's part of the fear. But also, I'm a human being. I'm an American. I want to get in there and I want these people to understand that we are good people and we are here to help them. So really, at that point, I'm sure you can hear it in my voice there, is that I know I can't fix it, I know I can't bring them back, but I want to make it better.
“那只是恐惧的一部分。但同时，我是一个人。我是美国人。我想进去，我想让这些人明白我们是好人，我们在这里是为了帮助他们。所以实际上，在那一点上，我相信你能从我的声音里听出来，我知道我无法修复它，我知道我不能让他们复活，但我希望能让情况好转。”
But out of respect, we waited 7 to 10 days, went to neighboring towns and villages and told them what was going on, and got the message out. And I know the message got to the people in the town. But then the following three weeks, we went in and did exactly what we were doing before. Was meet with people, and begin to develop, or rebuild relationships. And we continued to conduct operations, continued to pull bad guys out of the town.
“但出于尊重，我们等了7到10天，去了邻近的城镇和村庄，告诉他们发生了什么，并把信息传了出去。我知道消息传到了镇上的人们那里。但随后的三周里，我们进去了，做了我们以前一直在做的事情。就是与人们会面，开始发展或重建关系。我们继续进行行动，继续从镇上清理坏人。”
This is pretty much the standard way that he'd operate in these villages. He said, sure, there were some villages and local leaders who were sympathetic with the insurgents. But in other places, they were being bossed around by them.
这基本上就是他在这些村庄里的常规行事方式。他说，确实，有些村庄和当地领导人同情叛乱分子，但在其他地方，他们却受到叛乱分子的摆布。
A couple of terrorists who intimidated the leaders of that village could effectively control the entire village. People were scared to leave their houses. Kids stayed in the houses. Kids didn't go to school. So when you went in and you took those guys out, and you came back and said, yeah, I just caught this guy, this guy, and this guy. And I found all kinds of explosives, threat CDs, beheading CDs in their house, they're gone. They're never coming back. And the most incredible thing was you saw the change within a day. Within 24 or 48 hours, you would go back into that town and a town where kids would not even wave to you or kids would throw rocks at you, you'd go in the next day and they would be crowded around the humvees just wanting to touch you or talk to you.
“恐吓该村领导人的少数恐怖分子可以有效地控制整个村庄。人们害怕离开自己的房子。孩子待在屋里。孩子不去上学。所以当你进去把那些家伙抓走，回来告诉他们，是的，我刚才抓了这个家伙，那个家伙，还有那个家伙。我在他们家里发现了各种爆炸物、威胁光盘、斩首光盘，他们走了。他们再也不会回来了。最不可思议的是，你在一天之内就看到了变化。在24或48小时内，你会回到那个镇子，而在一个孩子们甚至不会跟你挥手或会向你扔石头的镇子，第二天你进去，他们会围在悍马车周围，只想触碰你或和你交谈。”
In Aitha, he says, people waited to see who was going to win-- the US led forces or the insurgents. Until there came a turning point.
在艾塔，他说，人们等待着看谁会赢——以美国为首的部队还是叛乱分子。直到出现了一个转折点。
There was a distinct turning point. The turning point was when the sheik of the town came to see me, which would never have happened before.
“有一个明显的转折点。转折点是镇上的谢赫来见我，这在以前是永远不会发生的。”
And do you remember what he said at the beginning, like so as to explain? What do you remember of what he said?
你还记得他一开始说了什么吗，为了解释？你还记得他说的什么吗？
What he said was I need your help. And that was it right there. I knew what was going to come after that.
“他说的是‘我需要你的帮助’。就是那样。我就知道接下来会发生什么。”
You know, just thinking about that accidental bombing, the way that it ended up working out, did that accidental bombing actually give you access to people and a way to meet with them and a reason to meet with them that you might not have had otherwise?
想到那次意外轰炸，以及它最终带来的结果，那次意外轰炸是否真的给了你接近人们、认识他们的途径，以及你本可能不会有的会面理由？
It wasn't that it gave us a reason to. We had a reason to, we're going to be in the town regardless. But it forced them to listen to us because they were so hurt by the incident and they began to understand what we were there for. And they eventually offered us forgiveness and asked for our help. And to this day, I probably have the strongest bond with that town than any other town over there.
“并不是它给了我们理由。我们有理由，无论如何我们要去那个镇上。但它强迫他们倾听我们，因为他们对那次事件感到非常受伤，他们开始理解我们是为了什么而来的。他们最终向我们提供了宽恕并请求我们的帮助。直到今天，我与那个镇的联系可能比那里任何其他镇子都要强。”
Of course, a month later, I knew we were going to have elections in the town. The town was secured by Iraqi security forces and it seemed like every five minutes the Iraqi security forces were coming under fire, we were coming under fire. The most incredible thing was the Iraqi security forces held their ground. They fought the terrorists off. A lot of fire, very intense night. And then that morning, about 4:00 in the morning, I remember sitting on the hill, all the American forces pulled out in the morning, so the Iraqi security forces could secure the actual election site during voting. I remember sitting on a hill overlooking the town of Aitha and the sun started to come up, and all of a sudden I realized, there was a line of about 1,000 people in front of the polling site. The whole town almost came out to vote. It was absolutely incredible.
当然，一个月后，我知道镇上要举行选举了。镇子由伊拉克安全部队保卫，看起来每五分钟伊拉克安全部队就会遭到开火，我们也会遭到开火。最不可思议的是伊拉克安全部队坚守阵地。他们击退了恐怖分子。交火很多，非常激烈的夜晚。然后第二天早上，大约凌晨4点，我记得坐在小山上，所有美军在早晨撤出，以便伊拉克安全部队能在投票期间保卫实际的选举地点。我记得坐在俯瞰艾塔镇的小山上，太阳开始升起，突然我意识到，投票点前排了大约1000人的队伍。整个镇子几乎都出来投票了。那绝对是不可思议的。”
Captain Ryan Gist and the 65 men that he commands returned safely to their base in Fort Lewis, Washington, at the end of last month.
瑞安·吉斯特上尉和他指挥的65名士兵于上个月底安全返回了华盛顿州路易斯堡的基地。
Act three. What do we do with these numbers anyway? So if in fact, 100,000 Iraqis died because of the war, and that number is a year old, or at least like Alex said in his report, there's a 90% probability that at the time it was over 44,000 dead, what do we do with that number? You know, the problem at the heart of the whole thing is that it instantly brings you to all of these imponderable questions about what is worth it. What is worth so many people dead?
第三幕。我们到底该如何看待这些数字？如果事实上有10万伊拉克人因为战争死亡，而那个数字已经是一年前的了，或者至少像亚历克斯在报道中所说，有90%的概率在当时死亡人数就已经超过4.4万，我们该怎么处理这个数字呢？你知道，整个问题的核心在于，它立刻把你带向所有关于“什么才是值得的”这种无法估量的问题。什么值得这么多人死亡？
And in a way, once I understood this number and believed this number, I wasn't even sure if it's a helpful thing to think about that. What do you do with that? So I called a woman named Nancy Sherman, who has the unusual set of jobs of being a philosophy professor at Georgetown University. And also, she's taught ethics at the US Naval Academy. She interviews military people, she writes about how they think in books like Stoic Warriors , and she thinks you do want to know how many civilians die in a war, so you can understand the trade-offs.
某种程度上，一旦我理解了这个数字并相信了这个数字，我甚至不确定思考它是否有所帮助。你拿它怎么办？所以我给一个叫南希·谢尔曼的女人打了电话，她担任着不同寻常的工作，既是乔治城大学的哲学教授，也曾在美军海军军官学校教授伦理学。她采访军人，在《斯多葛派战士》等书中撰写他们的思考方式，她认为你确实想知道有多少平民在战争中死亡，这样你才能理解权衡。
Now, many would argue that once you include the numbers of civilians killed, the trade-offs don't start looking so good. But of course, then there's the problem, what exactly are we measuring against? What's the good we're bringing about in the name of which violence is incurred?
现在，许多人会认为一旦你计入被杀害的平民人数，权衡就不那么美好了。但当然，随之而来的问题是：我们到底是在衡量什么？我们为了什么名义的善而招致了暴力？
Right. And that's where you get into such immeasurable things. Because if, in fact, a democracy is created in the Mideast and it changes the whole shape of the Mideast--
没错。那就是你陷入那些无法衡量的事情的地方。因为如果，事实上在中东创建了一个民主制度并改变了整个中东的格局——
That's right. But these goals and goods have to be tangible and there has to be evidence.
没错。但这些目标和善果必须是具体的，而且必须有证据。
I know, but the thing that seems so hard is we're measuring an actual concrete number against a benefit that really can't be measured at all. If by changing the shape of the Middle East we prevent a nuclear attack on New York City, or Cairo, or just anywhere, then it just changes the equation. And it seems like what you've got is you've got a certain number of dead bodies on one side, and then a future that's yet unlived on the other.
我知道，但似乎非常困难的事情在于我们正在衡量一个实际的具体数字，对照着一个根本无法衡量的利益。如果通过改变中东的格局，我们阻止了针对纽约、开罗或任何地方的核袭击，那它就改变了等式。看起来你手里拿的是一边有一定数量的尸体，另一边是一个尚未活过的未来。
Exactly. These kinds of calculations about how much cost can you incur in order to get a good at the end are very, very troublesome. Because when you're doing these kinds of calculations, you'd like to have a concrete good that's here and now existing. Numbers are always tricky, but the massiveness of numbers does matter. And when does the moral psyche break, at what number? I don't know. Tell me about Darfur. The world hasn't broken on that number yet and that seems pretty horrific to me.
正是如此。这种关于为了获得最终的善而必须付出多少成本的计算是非常非常令人困扰的。因为当你做这种计算时，你希望有一个实实在在的、当下存在的善。数字总是很棘手，但庞大的数字确实重要。那么道德心理在什么数字下会崩溃？我不知道。告诉我关于达尔富尔的事情。世界还没有因为那个数字而崩溃，那对我来说似乎非常恐怖。”
Nancy Sherman from Georgetown University.
乔治城大学的南希·谢尔曼。
Well, our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig and Amy O'Leary. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Sam Hallgren and Chris Ladd.
嗯，我们的节目今天由丽莎·波拉克和我自己制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、戴安·库克、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·柯尼格和艾米·奥利里参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。Sam Hallgren和Chris Ladd提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢名单）
You can download today's program at our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
您可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的存档中下载今天的节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（赞助商致谢）
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, whenever he finishes a budget or correctly orders lunch, he calls me into his office, leans back in his chair--
WBEZ管理层对我们的节目由托里·马拉蒂亚先生监督。你知道，每当他完成预算或正确点了午餐时，他就会叫我进他的办公室，靠在椅子上——
And he looks me and he says, whoever did this was a very smart man.
然后他看着我说，不管是谁做的，都是个非常聪明的人。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。